so it's my pleasure now to introduce the
first of our guest speakers for this
afternoon I met John back for let's
fight well let's step in you I met John
Mackey in 1982 when I was a you talk
student at the National mathematics
summer school and I remember that he
taught me that every integer is the
summer force quits and so we've had a
long relationship since then the other
thing he did was he told me on my HSC my
course before it was officially
available so John is an honorary
associate professor in the School of
Mathematics and statistics he's now
retired but before he was retired he was
professor of mathematics and head of the
academic core he's always been
passionate about school athletics he has
been president of the Australian
Association events teachers and he
became a life member in 1996 he was also
like member of mansburg the mathematical
Association of New South Wales
so in 2008 John was honored by a Queen's
Birthday Honours List where he is a
member of the Order of Australia and
that was for service to mathematics
education particularly in the area of
curriculum development to the arts and
to a range of academic professional
organizations so it's my pleasure to my
time John Mackay to give the first
one of the groups are belong to when I
first joined the staff of the University
used to meet once a month and it
consisted of some rather elderly types
like me now and some younger people then
the motto of it was that the old might
be quickened by the new and I must say
that being here today and experiencing
this morning's discussion has been a
very revitalizing experience for me and
I hope that those of you who are still
on the beginnings of your careers
realize there's a great deal to be
gained by sharing experiences and
learning new things all the time I think
as a teacher it's important to let your
students know but you're also learning
because we're learning all the time and
that phrase about lifelong learning
there's not an inky phrase it's really
important now my topic here are HSC
subjects and this is far too big a topic
to talk about in a finite time so we're
just speaking some generality but the
important thing is I think to remember
that the early years of your life of
really years when you've got to develop
your own abilities to the maximum and
the most important organ in anybody's
body is their brain the brain uses the
highest proportion of energy that your
body produces and one of your functions
as a teacher is to make sure that you
develop the brain
of your students to the maximum and in
mathematics it's a very excellent area
in which you can encourage mental
development so I have a very strong
belief that being a maths teacher is a
really important role in a school
whether you teach other things or not
with regard to the HSC first thing to
remember is that at present not every
student majoring year 11 has the same
sort of types of subjects as they might
were they in a different school we're
still a long way from equity of access
but Maryland mentioned is a really
important thing this morning the next
thing is that it is not all that easy
even now with the wealth of information
around us to get an understanding of the
sorts of things that will really help
you go in that important transition from
school to post-school the HSC
is certainly a really important
milestone in that it's been made so in
our society we've increased the
participation rate up to the end of year
12 quite significantly in my lifetime
and there are plans to make more and
more of the cohort of students age group
complete an HSC so when you are thinking
about advising students on the sorts of
courses they might take start but make
sure they're really beginning to think
about this in year not because post year
nine
ready the case that you may be limiting
your opportunity businesses feel don't
expect them to take it very seriously
year 12 is too far away to worry about
if you read near 9 for most people but
it is important to keep stressing the
fact that there are some subjects like
mathematics which really are very useful
for general intellectual development and
I would emphasize that the HSC is
something which is in many ways not
found easily in other countries what I
really like about it is the wide choice
of subjects that are available to
students entering year 11 than going on
the year 12 sometimes I find I also
dislike it because I think the choice is
too wide and maybe students wittingly or
unwittingly making subject choices that
in the end they might regret a few years
later let me just mention briefly there
are about 55,000 students who qualified
for an ATAR
in recent years you know how many units
you have to do to qualify for an HSC
most of you know that you can do that by
completing five or six courses we still
have fortunately a reasonable number of
students who do more than I mean
number of courses but in 30 seconds how
many different subject combinations do
you think students presenting at the HSC
give a little bit of thought for that
55,000 students anyone like Thank You
Neville is going to consider what I'm
about to say and I'm not being terribly
precise there over 26 26 2001 certainly
over 20,000 different subject
combinations presented in the HSC in
reserve students do take advantage of
the diversity of choice and you've got
to keep that in mind now one of the
disadvantages of being a maths teacher
especially in the upper years of high
school is that when the students in your
class say why do I have to do this when
no other subject that I'm studying for
the HSC appears to require any
mathematics because that's the case most
of them only require a little bit of
primary school mathematics or even the
physics course doesn't require much
beyond about
I think your answer is well I don't know
why there was so little mathematics
evident in many of the other subjects
when if you're going to study those at
university you will find that you need a
reasonable body of mathematics that
helped me get through I'm a bit
disappointed that our general curriculum
is really so focused on keeping Matz in
the maths classroom I would much prefer
to see applications of mathematics
appear in the subject theory aware the
application occurs rather than more and
more of the demand being put on the math
teacher to include an example of that in
your classes so think globally about the
future careers of your students think to
try to get them to understand that
learning and achieving in mathematics is
really mentally very important and it's
going to open up doors that you may find
it hard to struggle through if you defer
taking up the serious study of
mathematics it's a really important
thing I recently saw a full double page
spread in well-known magazine called The
New Yorker it was by Exxon Mobil which
is a pretty big global company it had a
picture of a young girl head down over a
open book with a pencil and up in the
top corner it simply said eight out of
ten careers in this century will require
a knowledge of maths and science in a
country like Australia that's going to
be terribly significant because mining
and agriculture and so on although they
generate a lot of money for us you don't
need many people
those industries these days because of
advances in technology if we're going to
get successful employment for a lot of
our future where they're going to have
to be employed in areas where
intellectual and creative abilities are
paramount that's one of the child
challenges that we all face and I hope
and I really believe after we see than
what was going on this morning that in
front of me are a lot of people who are
going to help our students achieve those
career goals thank you